you know I mean what you like about the
European government they can only about
money yeah they look I told you the
money they tell you because they're
Muslim country if if a place is a mosque
you know allowed to send it to anything
else
yeah most all the time you understand
yeah because it works you know
subhanallah so you see the name of Islam
and you see how is that impact people in
reality because Christianity is a theory
belief meaning that it's not in a
reality it's not something that you can
Implement it's beyond the church God
love you but it's them no it's for the
Layman and for the government too don't
want to say something even when I see
all your download videos
every time you ask a car if it's a
Christian does it make sense is it
logical yeah every time they said yes
I've never seen anyone say no yeah
even if they don't even if they don't
accept Islam at that time straight away
but they always say it makes sense is it
clear it's rational logical because why
I mentioned that why is that is the only
religion of Allah because when you look
at Islamic teaching and you look to our
nature when someone explained Islam to
you naturally you start gravitating
towards Islam you understand because the
one who created you with those tools
within you is the same one who sent down
the Revelation that's why they click in
but only the Christianity go against
ourselves listening Judaism is a tribal
God you know it's just God don't care
about only group of people the rest in
the standard that's why even though
there's a huge war against Islam and as
I've mentioned many times if this world
has been waged by the mean media in the
western world and everyone else it was
against any religion that religion would
be that long time ago but guess what
look this is dirty and disgusting and a
huge war against Islam yet Islam is not
just defending is spreading
subhanallah because why it's not because
we're Muslims doing the job because
Allah is doing the job
in the Quran
you know Allah said Allah says
it's
Prophet with a true religion
there's no Muslims who left Islam I'm
not saying that but overall Islam is
spreading he works at Islam
alhamdulillah you know even though as
I've mentioned
there is many many barriers against
Islam you know it's not oppressed woman
Islam oppress this that's what they're
saying it but
of rivers are women yeah
but you know but you know now yeah I
wanna I wanna mention something I think
Europeans they cannot speak about Islam
oppressed women
you know why
because now you're up in the Western
World they don't know what woman is
they don't know
literally men can be woman yeah yeah
they don't know they don't know so so
when they say Islam oppressed woman what
do you mean by that they find women
they cannot Define women have you seen
that program with this american guy he
was going on there I was asking Define
woman a woman she said I cannot Define
woman
so the Western World they cannot tell us
if you are oppressing woman or not
there is a man that raped a woman raped
two women yeah what happened the day
that he was going to the courts to get a
sentence he's just like a woman and he
say I identify myself as a woman now
where do I have to put him woman prison
rape woman prison yeah I'd have to put
him because he's a woman he said now
that place is like paradise for him
that's what he wants
but Allah mention that in the Quran
women are rather than
ever since away from our remembrance
then you will have a miserable life and
that's what we see now you know it's
crazy bro
that's a similar thing because
you take it you take a new desires as
God only take your desires as God then
you start today this Halal tomorrow
change your mind tomorrow is halal like
you know now like I said they cannot
tell us as a woman or as a man
in the stand
look this guy
huh I'm sweet enough you know
the way you break it down you give down
the way you break it down like you give
examples about simple example the two
million pounds and he gives the
prophecies
no philosophy no long-winded discussions
I was going into the root of the Kalam
Cosmos this gets confusing and you
couldn't negate yeah yeah like how you
said yeah and the way you break it down
is easier to digest it's all of these
word arguments we're playing it's just
too much and why they why they are using
this scientifical way to prove Allah's
existence or cosmological way because
some Muslims they have inferiority
complex so what's the Western World so
they have to they have to
debate them according today style and
according to their standard however they
say because they are different than us
but sahaba when they went to Persia and
roma doesn't sign they were different
than the Arab Muslims I mean the
Byzantine philosophy was there Persian
they were philosophers many philosophies
likewise sahaba never said you know what
um
now we're reaching Berger over Richmond
Byzantine remember the people are
different they are spiritualized they
wait no they were proud he said
something as well like yeah them
accepting Islam is not your criteria
this the Quran is a Criterion
now people Allah raise upon us to convey
the message
there is some guys here they'll be
speaking to some Muslim brothers because
speaking some atheists here for hours
discussion and I haven't accept Islam
you know why because those atheists then
are seeking the truth
you know they're not seeking the truth
and they know Islam is the truth so what
you do you have to remind them with
Allah's verse about the Hellfire and the
punishment that's the quranic style you
know
I remember you talked about one one
conversation had an atheist and he also
said he must have said to him are you
sure you're here he's like I'm not sure
you're 100 sure he said I'm 99 I might
be asleep and you said that every week
they'll come with a new argument
now this person cannot become Muslim
because if he becomes a Muslim and he
still have his belief there's always
doubt Muslim have to have certainty
so this guy is gonna doubt said maybe
Islam is true but there is some one
point percent Islam is not true you care
because Islam is the truth with billion
certainty no doubt about it you
understand so if a person says that what
I'm going to spend my waste my time with
him telling him like one of them I said
to him are you are you in front of me he
said are you asking me etymologically
yeah that guy that guy oh yeah I'm
asking you a
questionologically anthropologically
psychologically cosmologically and you
know the term they use big terms and if
it asks they sound smart but if you
investigate the market they're dumb no
smartness the smartness that's what
Allah in the Quran mentioned
they said if we use our intellect and
our hearing then we wouldn't have been
from the people of the fire what does
that mean they don't have internet no
they had intellect but they never allow
the intellect to function according to
the way Allah created it they were
Poisoned With skepticism philosophy
nonsensical things you see so then I
guess then in nature just for the sake
of rejecting Allah
I'll give you example let's listen to
this yeah I'm speaking to a sister she
said to me she had some doubts yeah
so she said to me I said look you have
to watch Allah's blessings she said to
me but Allah Allah never asked me
before he created me Allah never asked
me before creating me yeah
so African look this is my skin yeah but
this question doesn't make any sense why
because if Allah watch this
she wants to yes what are you saying
good she wants a lot according to her
desires firstly secondly if Allah if
Allah has to ask you then what he has to
do that's to create you but if Allah
creates you then you have to understand
he's your lord and your servants you
have to submit to him
doesn't make any sense why is this
called
service Tree Service tree they will ask
questions the first part of the question
refute the last part or the last part
review the first part and this group
called existed before Plato and
Aristotle they existed to create what
they were doing in debate and
discussions they still create questions
for the sake of confusing people and
some people what they do they entertain
the question then what happened we just
cause more confusion you bring an answer
to something does not need the answer
why needs rebuking and showing the
nonsensical question you understand it
doesn't make any sense what Allah create
me never ask me but if you ask you and
you know he's your Lord the Almighty the
path with the Creator the one that owns
everything and you are a servant I was
gonna ask you
doesn't make any sense
doesn't make any sense it's actually
going to work and you know when you're
going to work and you know this is the
boss and you have to follow the boss and
you say you know what why you don't tell
me what I I should tell you what to do
I'm gonna say no no there's
misunderstanding here I'm the boss you
understand that's why when you they
bring these questions but when they go
to work they have no problem
their money just to control them what
time they go to the bathrooms they have
no problem with that
literally
if you work from nine to five you can go
to bathroom every second the boss will
say to listen your break is midday and
he says thank you sir
there will be any nonsensical disease uh
evil question why because your heart and
your soul is poisoned that's what Allah
said
the one that because we have enough and
our nurse is like a baby just wants more
and more animals to to justify the Haram
so we have to cultivate it and control
it you understand so Allah puts it
enough us to test us others is gonna
overpower us or we have to overpower it
how we overpower it
understand not by philosophy philosophy
just increase your more in darkness and
disease and Mara Denmark us that the
Muslims are utilized philosophy they
don't use it to establish Akita in of
itself however they use it as a defense
mechanism to counter argue the arguments
that these philosophers bring so we are
not in need of that because that bring
more confusion but like
so
so how do but the thing is if you ask a
philosopher
the principles of logic yeah he presents
like you can't just say to them because
Allah said it obviously they don't
accept the premise of Allah to begin
with no no wait wait
firstly I'm not saying you have to say
Allah said it straight away from the
Quran and I'm not saying don't you sound
reasoning the philosophical reason is
not sound reasoning okay so why are you
suggested so what you did when a
philosopher came to you you are already
submitting to his way
so let's not say philosophy about
it
meaning we don't we don't play with them
we go from our grounds
no that's what they said before before
that I agree answer what you're saying
yeah you saying that we use philosophy
or Kalam which is a part of philosophy
we use it to refute them not to
establish our religion yeah yeah I can't
say yeah okay the sahaba when they went
to Persian Rome is there
this way
to people in Medina he gave down to
Jewish people and remember Jewish people
don't have the influenced by philosophy
too do you Prophet Muhammad telling them
and all of this oh there is a there's
attributes or there is part and no Allah
Allah said Prophet Muhammad said or if
someone said he said some people what
they do because they've already been
praised in the Quran they hate Quran so
what you do you get the arguments in the
Quran
you know from the Quran and he said
either you create yourself
or you create by nothing you understand
what they say they find nothing
what are you doing Muslims who love this
the way of talking he starts going to
nothing then he forgets the main points
from
[Music]
history
as far as I'm
they
in the religion who started first
the main figures
okay he met people called sumania
sumania people that do not believe in
Allah okay and they ask him have you
seen you go question these are bringing
doubt okay
was influenced by
Greek philosophy and the Sumerian or
Sumerian and um
okay sybians yeah
so now foreign
attributes
philosophy is a disease that's what the
argument was our arguments we cannot use
Quran soon against them because they
don't believe
okay so what I have to use dayways but
they was corrupted and it's not upon you
because I understand you can show them
like it will tell me yeah I supposed to
study philosophy not to use it to refuse
that we are not in need of it
that was aim that's why it's always
Sunnah in the stand so philosophy that
was used
he was speaking to other students
and he started using he said leave that
it's a disease
is dangerous because bless you
philosophy has a lot of ambiguity
you understand for example
they say Allah is spaceless
have you heard that spaces okay what do
you think about the statement
it depends what the intent of the
meaning behind it is correct because
spaceless what do you mean by that
we're in the full uh
they used it to negate allies above the
creation
what do you mean by that you understand
because we see Allah is above the
creation you want to call it space or
not it's up to you but if you say space
that is created and Allah is surrounded
by his creation we reject that if you
say means Allah is
creation we accept that and that's what
the Quran teaches they say Allah is
timeless
Timeless yeah again this term Timeless
is known the Quran why this this stem
was used to negate Allah eternally as a
Creator
eternally is the most merciful to negate
Allah's actions
but is that I don't think that's the way
they intended when they say meaning they
mean time as in the creation of Allah so
that's what you're intent that's why
then you get Allah eternally that's what
they say everything
are they using language to frame the
conversation they're using a term that
is a disease it's a poison you know
that's why we're not in need of that
defend Islam
and Nam you can give analogies
atheists and he said to them if I tell
you there is a boat
and a boat has it's been loaded with
many items and it was sweeping or
um what they call it on the Seas going
slowly and smoothly until it reaches the
shore
and he said that's crazy without uh no
one said he said what about his creation
the upper why are you showing them
this creation must have there's
knowledge behind it and there's all that
behind it you know like what so we see
the seller for years a sound reason our
knowledge is like Prophet Muhammad when
a man came to him he said oh messenger
of Allah
I'm a white person my wife is white and
we have a black child
he said because of what because of the
lineage like once Offspring was red he
said likewise so he used What analogy no
problem but when you come to philosophy
that we use which clearly opposed Sunnah
that's right
and he said if Allah moves because it's
based upon the 10 categories of
Aristotle
that God is this must be moving
motionless Timeless spaceless you know
all of this time we're not in need of it
because if you accept the term already
it's dangerous if you're going to study
it and you only started to understand
correctly with clear proofs and you want
to study philosophy to refuse it and
expose their way alhamdulillah that's
what they said
before
foreign
[Music]
right um
the Western Science Now is based upon
the Greek philosophy
you know it's based upon the great
philosophy no doubt and I would advise
people for this to read The Works
likewise one of the doctors and from
Egypt could I will see that Force
martial arts articles in English or
Arabic and I'll give you his name and
check it for both of them check they
have two lectures about philosophy and
the danger of and how animals
it's upon you to guide people yes Folks
up I'll give you example
imagine there's you know the concept of
evil yeah
some Muslims have written the books to
the Futures yeah
that doesn't make any sense to me
you know why
why okay I can refuse it easily without
writing a book
you know why they had to write a book
because you know what to repeat the
concept of evil you know why because
some Muslims abide by the way of the
western philosophers
you have to prove everything yes you
have to prove everything and now will we
know that
Allah is the creator of everything
whatever occurs there's a wisdom behind
it simple okay you can give examples
but it's known
so when you start debating in depth
about it you bring more confusion than
Clarity because why they said the
hardest thing to prove is the most
obvious thing
but that's a good point as well though
when he says that philosophy changes
through times and places so when you get
the statements of the seller we rebuked
philosophy
do you not think that the philosophy
they were referring to was that
philosophy used by German
no no no no no it's the same because why
philosophy wise in our time like I said
philosophers in our time not Japanese
one time in our time
if you tell them
they accept it
wrote a book about how to prove that
already yet
there's no need proof that's
constriction because that area is
self-evident
is that you proving to me I'm speaking
to you that doesn't make any sense so
from that that's what I'm saying okay
there is certain things that's why Islam
comes with
addressing that already yet
foreign it doesn't have evil Hearts will
accept it but someone who is poisoned
has an evil heart will never be
satisfied with anything like even even
if you bring even if you use philosophy
which of your doubts about uh even they
have another question you understand
they will have even like for example uh
sorry because I'm speaking more forgive
me about the club you know there's a
brother America he tried to refute the
doubts and never ask God to create me
why create me yeah I never asked
because it doesn't make any sense one
brother said you know what he said he
said
I would say to this guy imagine if you
wake up and you see food front of you
yeah food front of you and you eat it
would you not thank me
you were saying to me he said yeah yeah
but someone who has evil Hearts like
philosophers generally speak what he
says he said yeah but if I don't eat it
and I eat I don't say thank you will you
punish me why are you gonna punish me
we'll bring it out but salafi comes in
your question doesn't make any sense
because if you need Allah to ask you
then he has to create you if Allah
creates you you already submit that he's
the Creator and you are the Creator he's
the Lord of everything then he should
submit to him we don't question him
foreign
[Music]
do you know the people sorry you know
why people don't you know everyone
there's a middle ground bird because I
know people who are sincere and
genuinely ask philosophical questions
who come from us is here they're asking
from his point of sincerely but there's
no way specific question for example
give me an example of that because I'm
not saying if someone's gonna say it
like understand me correctly I'm the
lazy I mean I've been here 15 years I'll
give that one anyone even they come with
the most lucrative question has to
answer it and if I see that sincere
Academy
let's go back to something I want to
mention you said about the father do not
believe Allah Allah so there's no point
to them Allah said yeah yeah that's not
correct that's that's incorrect what he
said you know why no I mean I said that
they don't believe in the premise of
Allah so to say Allah said to them yeah
but you don't have to say Allah said I
understand he said that but even he said
Allah said because you want to accept
your no you don't accept it because when
Allah said something it's not just when
Allah said something it's something
which any human being with the sound
reasoning and the sound natural
explanation will gravitate towards it
maybe it has some doubt it can refute it
let me bring you back show you the
danger of your statement
they never believed in day of judgment
except the time
so why Allah is threatening them with
day of judgment when they don't even
believe in a day of judgment
[Music]
Because deep down they do believe by the
two arrogant to submit to submit to that
so let us use the quranic way the
quranic way you know Quran is powerful
that's what Allah Quran has intellectual
arguments and psychological arguments
some people regardless how much
intellectual argument they're too
arrogance to accept that so what you do
you change that fear Allah and you're
gonna stand before Allah regardless how
many times you're going to try to use a
nonsensical argument against your
creator you will die and there's a
punishment for you you know
and you don't have to say it loudly say
you're gonna die and stand before you go
the one that created you if you accept
it leave him with this in the stand so
that's that's that if you say so there's
many versions of judgment friend them
with the punishment with the Hellfire
because they believe in it but because
the the why people don't accept why
people don't offer Islam either
psychological reason
or a social reason
s
or social Factor what do I mean by
psychological Factor psychological
Factor the person's arrogance he knows
the truth or he knows that Islam teaches
something which is forbidden that he
desires and he likes but he's not going
to tell you some people don't say it
openly I like this and that's why I
don't become Muslim but I'm assertive
times he's gonna try to justify his
disbelief I'm not accepting Islam by
courts and quotes philosophical
arguments and intellectual arguments or
a social Factor like I believe Bob and
other than them they believe Islam is
the truth but because people look after
them amongst their community so what
they do they start looking for any
argument against Islam to justify their
disbelief or they know if by accepting
Islam their own family go against them
you understand so that's what he boils
down to no he pulls down Islam is not
clear to them
any human being doing that for the last
15 years agree safe any human being
whose sound reason non-muslim atheists
agnostic I suppose to a woman from lgbtq
Community she was a lesbian the first
one I spoke to
she said you know what I want to become
Muslim
well lie why are you she's 80. I use the
Quran Allah said
you know but some people should be said
if they have something Allah said the
shutdown straight away just get the
argument
in your 15 years of discussions have you
found more people come with emotional
argument rather than an intellectual one
no no people come there's no one can no
one can reject Islam because in sexual
arguments
emotional yeah it never happened when I
was a little kid with a father or
something like that yeah yeah like my
father like a person said I don't want
to become Muslim because when I was
young my father did something to me she
was a girl I said look
emotional arguments and Allah tells us
all our time because you know even the
qurani mentions that Allah will tell us
and see the prophets and the people that
believed in him with him they say when
Allah will happen they'll be shaken by
the the the the tests and the child and
tribulation there's a wisdom behind it
but you know what we have to teach our
brothers and sisters
that understand you nothing Allah
destroyed Nations before us Allah
of mercy upon him said he said we live
in a time when people become rebellious
and guess God
and these people you can remind them but
also remind them with a threats and with
Jannah
bless you say compare with the people
that use philosophy and the people used
to understand accept Islam by way of
people look because of me or because
those brothers who is because of the
lesson
discussions
[Music]
some people might say that that is
logic yeah you see now I understand that
yeah but that's not it's not because
right firstly philosophical arguments
philosophy we know what is it like I
said philosophy is based upon our
skepticism
in the Quran you have to prove that
first
but the Quran for example of that
Etc they say you have to prove to me
but for that accept evidence how we
proved
if I prove to you it's a federal then
the faitha needs to proved
I don't agree with this guys
the 10 categories which is about God
okay the love no contradiction also
never had it everyone knows that a child
knows that can you tell me I mentioned
example of that Dimension
no but but the philosophers they say no
that is just they will explain to you
understand that's why I'm saying don't
entertain them because everything they
can be done about everything
fine line between like a logical group
the first difficult argument you have to
prove it you have to prove it what is
not a necessity a logical argument you
don't need to prove the argument is
prove by itself
rhetorical question are you sure are you
are you okay that this video is great
but nothing you understand of course
Allah I understand like in our own words
there's no need this proof is not needed
you understand that's why you know
because the Messengers
uh address
are you doubted Allah now in the western
world and many women they doubt Allah
the most obvious thing
and you know who shot it will you try to
prove the most obvious thing
you go for long that's why this is
awesome our brothers
because what every problem is proof
every problem is proof every proof but
Islam comes in with the starting points
the philosophers they live off starting
points to go to look for the starting
point that they left
left it
so you know with the federal I've seen
you're right because I've seen
philosophers say that the fitra is a
parallel to the child parent conflicts
yeah in my opinion I think they just
bring too much
[Music]
that's good because
I mean I'll check the things
that has been fire and there is nobody
to help him yeah you will ask God that's
true
he know about it you know what I really
ever mentioned you know there's a
federal if someone if atheists
how the atheist says you know the
question the question eight is prove
Allah's existence and approve they say
if there is no no why there is evil who
said evil is not good
where'd you get that from you understand
something good in them not something
within them tell them it was not good so
who created you with that you've been
programmed if it's not good but you just
misunderstand that Allah Allah will evil
because there's a test in order for
there's many wisdom behind it yeah they
say oh there's no good news
yeah I know man as soon as they accept
it through the evil it has to be a God
you know something even last week not
last week I saw a video where you had a
discussion with a guy and he was putting
the problem of evil he brought him the
arguments about the attributes of Allah
the wisdom life is a test yeah afterlife
and the Free World and then next week he
came to taking shahada from America the
American brother yeah he was the same
Allah keeping firm you know have you
lost in the video when the guy told me
he said I think it's a dream yeah yeah
[Laughter]
I said it's a dream bye-bye you know
there's another one for long yeah he
said there's nothing certain so I still
had this phone I give this one at the
end I
[Laughter]
why because you put him in the real test
that's why my brothers many people come
speak his Corner debate against Islam
will lie the argument that they use they
will never live by it when they go
outside the park
we're alive
that's it you know but as Allah said
except these believers
these Believers they're arrogant all of
us are clear why do you think you see
with skepticism
in their life their daily life they're
already skeptical like about the doctor
by their family but when it comes to God
they flip the logic yeah I mean they
still have skepticism there's one which
is praise you know that but the
blameworthy like you start doubting
everything yeah so you start doubting
even your own selves
like one of them are speaking to him
yeah
thank God
you told me there's no certainty
so there's possibility what prophet
Muhammad did was right he said yes I
said you're confused then go back but a
form of skept yeah
we found we find in the Quran as well
when Ibrahim obviously when he's a young
and he sees his parents uh his father
worshiping their idols and then he looks
to the stars and then he looks to the
moon and he looks at the Sun and so
that's not the self never explained that
I don't know but that obviously is no
that he was showing his people he was
asking like for example I said like
imagine you bring me a book I said this
is my God
yeah this is not it's not it's not
telling them he's doubting itself no
he's showing him the the foolishness of
believing this is God you understand
that's not this that's what the ulam
mentioned the correct strongest that
everyone assessment was not doubting how
Ibraham is going to doubt uh Allah
he's already he already destroyed idols
foreign
occurred amongst nations in two ways one
in galaxies the universe the other ones
in righteous and idols Ibrahim his
people they were having a shook in
galaxies to believe galaxies and the Sun
and the Moon they somehow have effects
on the universe and control so he was
showing them like he did with
the idols you understand I said
but they just use the arguments from it
to present it to these people and say
well listen this is what you're doing on
the on the premise of logic what is the
premise of logic
well it depends what you're talking
about
I don't accept the premise of logic are
you using you have to prove to me this
premise first
exactly but obviously obviously there's
regularities and patents within the
universe that there's things obviously
like the law of non-production
contradiction and all this stuff yeah
but they bring doubt it they prove to me
that doesn't happen that's my point as
you say we say we did because you know
safe yeah safe you have to remember what
we're talking about philosophy is a
marriage is a disease philosophies like
we accept that they don't believe that
yet and now when you accept they
method their method is based upon trying
to prove everything you understand so
when we tell them let us
based upon our argument on these
premises then as I prove this premises
is the premises itself
so a Muslim what it does ah doesn't
understand that and it's not proving and
it starts playing oh he says no this is
not by necessity then I say no you are
like I won
that's why the share error on the matter
with this they say is open
another first
you should not just blind follow you
understand but believing our line or
blind following you are following the
president and the Ugly selling you
understand so that's take us back you
prove in my points okay okay let's
demonstrate a safe you're speaking to a
philosopher atheist philosophers yeah
what is the premise that you're gonna
agree with
what is the starting point I'm no expert
in philosophy okay you watch Muhammad
Asia's videos he's speaking some guys
for two hours
the guy's bringing doubt he's refusing
it bringing another doubt his refuge in
it that is not some people maybe
yes and if you speak to him but you
don't you can show in the construction
of this philosophy but I'm saying okay
don't understand it for a long time and
don't judge defend Islam I'm not
defending Islam like for example I'm not
defending Islam we're not so the guy
give me the phone I'm gonna show him the
stupidity of his claim the foolishness
for him to wake up in the stand the
foundation but he could you remember
this guy abdulillah you can see Mala
guiding he woke up straight away but if
there's another philosopher maybe if
he's a philosopher who has disease he
can bring another argument against you
he says
and you have to understand that no
simple you know remember that Prophet
that he was talking to that so he didn't
know if he was there
the prophet I said he didn't know that
was there yeah I had talked to him and
he had broken down the premise already
yeah he came to UT as they asked me the
exact same question yeah well I spoke to
Sabor for three hours he spoke to
Muhammad for two hours
agent guy spoke to him three hours
for two hours yeah but to be honest
majority of Brothers speak to him and
happened to him in the past I'm not
gonna tell you what never happened to me
it happened to me the past when I speak
to some atheists I understand the
argument for hours and I'll leave them
without giving a remind about their
judgment
you accept
you're going to be the gender
um
okay where's the brothers uh